we just keep finding out about more and
more deleted and cut scenes from
Avengers in game and Avengers infinity
war what's up everyone it's Warren and
we have recently learned of a deleted
scene with young Thanos that is somewhat
of an origin story as to how he started
to go about balancing the universe
now after Avengers infinity war came out
we learned that there were a lot of
scenes cut that included Dana's his
childhood and origin story but
unfortunately we never got too much
information about them but luckily for
us the writers of Avengers infinity war
and Avengers in game have opened up and
told us a little bit about what those
deleted scenes of young danos were and
the good news is that we still may see
these scenes with the young Thanos and
his origin story later on in the MCU and
I'll talk about that in this video quick
reminder if you'd like a chance to win
an Xbox one or a ps4 be sure to
subscribe to my channel like this video
and comment below with your favorite
superhero or villain I'll be picking a
new winner at 500,000 subscribers so
again thanks to the writers for Avengers
infinity war and Avengers endgame
Christopher Markus and Stephen McFeely
we now know what this deleted young fan
owes origin story scene is in Avengers
infinity war on Titan we hear those tell
Doctor Strange about how his planet and
people died he said that his planet was
running out of resources too many mouths
to feed and not enough food and fan has
proposed a solution which was kill half
the population at random this is
apparently the scene that we could have
seen in Avengers infinity war or
Avengers end game a young fan oohs
talking to a council or a Senate on
Titan we would have heard a young fan
oohs tell the Senate that the only way
to save the planet was to eliminate half
of the population now obviously we know
how that went the Senate would reject
Santos's proposal but the planet and the
population would die this origin story
of Thanos would have been really cool to
see on screen but the writers have
revealed why they chose to leave this
scene out Christopher Marcus said that
part of the reason it went away is it
got a little too jor-el on Krypton
making his case you know it was the sort
of thing you could imply without having
to see so they chose not to put this
scene in and they chose to talk about
his origin in the scenes with Doctor
Strange and Gamora and when talking
about that decision stephen mcfeely said
it's a scene that's only doing one thing
what we settled on were all those scenes
that explained any history he had with
maura those are doing more than one
thing because they're highlighting his
relationship with his daughter he's
going to have to sacrifice so basically
they left out the scene with young
Thanos because it only did one thing it
only told fan s's origin story whereas
the scenes with Doctor Strange and
Gamora told his origin story but also
contributed to moving the movie forward
however we still could possibly see a
version of young Thanos in the MCU it is
widely believed that Thanos could be in
the Eternals movie for those of you who
do not know that os-- is an eternal he
just has the deviant gene but both of
his parents are Eternals and his brother
as well so it is widely believed that we
could be seen a young version of Thanos
in the Eternals movies since it is going
to take place thousands of years before
the events of Avengers infinity war and
Avengers endgame in fact we even have
official concept art of what the
Eternals could look like that includes a
young version of Thanos so even though
this scene was ultimately cut from
Avengers infinity war and Avengers in
game we could still see a version of
this scene in the MCU later on down the
road so would you have liked to have
seen this scene in Avengers infinity war
and would you like to see Thanos make a
return just a younger version down the
road and the Eternals be sure to comment
down below and comment with your
favorite superhero or villain liked this
video and subscribe to my channel for a
chance to win an Xbox one or a ps4 and
of course to stay up to date on
everything relating to the MCU don't
forget to follow me on Twitter and
Instagram and as always thank you all so
much for watching
woof woof